the alien franchise is coming back in a
big way welcome to S Che your Sci-Fi TV
and Movie
[Music]
Channel so Disney have big plans for
aliens and we're going to see the
Xenomorphs once again on the big screen
and on the little screen so back in July
the series started filming in Thailand
and even though the sagaa strikes had
started production continued for a month
because a lot of the cast are British
and they had an agreement basically with
the equity which is our version of sagaa
for them to continue but as the strikes
got a little bit Messier back in August
it was decided for production to Halt I
can tell you that right now in tyland
they are preparing to begin filming
again and that the second deal with
sagra is struck it's actually by the
time this video goes out I suspect might
have already happened filming will start
the actors will be recalled and filming
will restart quickly the plan is to get
this show on our screens by roughly the
summer of next year to coincide with
when the movie is released so yes we are
getting alien Romulus a cinematic movie
and around the same time we're hoping to
get the alien TV series on FX so an
exciting time to be a xenomorph fan but
what do we know about both projects so
first of all the movie Alien Romulus
this is being directed by fed Alvarez a
guy that you will know from quite a few
horror movies in the past he has said
that this is going to be a very young
cast and to be fair the cast of this
film go on IMDb you'll know some of
their faces but you won't know any of
their names hopefully though after this
movie movies released and is a massive
hit you will know their names and I
really like it when films do this when
they do a big movie a big budget film
but they have good actors but none of
them are big names because to be honest
the alien the xenomorph for me is the
star you don't need Tom Cruz in it
Alvarez though has said that this film
is going to be very dark and very
frightening and again go and have a look
at his IMDb and a couple of the films
he's done in the past if this guy says
this film is going to be frightening I
think we can rest assured it's probably
going to be quite frightening and him
saying that it's going to be dark to be
honest that is music to my ears I want
something that harks back to the
original 1979 alien movie I want that
Thriller intensity I want to see
something that's going to make me jump
out of my skin and I think this guy is
the guy to do it so what's roughly the
storyline going to be
well again AL has said that this is
going to break new territory but when
you actually read the very loose
synopsis of the movie I'm not so sure
for one it's supposed to be set between
the events of alien and aliens and it is
going to be in Space the young cast are
a crew of a Starship that basically
lands somewhere and low and behold finds
a xenomorph has a little bit of a tussle
and is basically fighting for that lives
the entire movie now if this is one
xenom morph again it will feel more like
alien and that I think is actually more
terrifying aliens became an action movie
really quickly because there was just so
many of them it was lots of gunfire it
was lots of explosions and death the
alien movie though I felt was far more
tense because it was the one xenomorph
it was the one enemy it was the one
villain if you like so that is what I
mean by is it really breaking new
territory because it does sound like
this film might be at least in part
inspired by the original alien film and
may go along those lines I don't know
how he's going to do something that's
particularly different if that's the
case oh no not
again
oh I hope he doesn't mean by neity that
we're just going to see lots of
CGI the guy has done some really
interesting really suspenseful stuff in
the past though so I don't think that's
going to be a major risk and at the end
of the day Ridley Scott has seen a very
early version of this film and he effing
loved it to use his words before I talk
about the TV series though I wanted to
talk about the great Bill Paxton that
died in 2017 you ever play Russian
rouer of course not what am I thinking
he was just one of those actors that I
always loved in everything I ever saw in
him he played a brilliant slimy CIA
villain in the movie Two Guns with Mark
wallberg and Denzel Washington just
before he passed away a film that if you
haven't seen
you must go and watch it's it's a proper
old school buddy movie and Bill Paxton
is astonishing in it I enjoyed him
following after tornadoes I loved him as
the bullying turd of a big brother in
Weird Science I basically loved him in
everything I ever saw and why do I bring
him up now because he's the only actor
that has the honor of being absolutely
slaughtered by a Terminator a predator
and a
xenomorph no other actor can say they
got killed by those bad guys and it
really is just a shame that Bill Paxton
did pass away when he did because I'd
have loved to have seen him get
slaughtered One More Time by a xenomorph
Noah Hy is the showrunner of the FX
series that is hopefully going to be on
our screens as I say roughly this time
next year now we know filming as I said
has started we know some of the casting
please go and check out the
IMDb we know hope y when it's going to
be set because this is actually going to
be a prequel set before the 1979 alien
movie now that movie was supposedly set
in
2122 and the TV series is supposed to be
set 70 years before that so roughly
2050 so in the relatively near future
and thanks to no Hy we know the film is
going to be based here on Earth around
two or three competing companies now we
know there's going to be wh and utani
and potentially other companies or maybe
wayand is separate at that point and
utani is there come overtake him I don't
know but that is going to be the basic
premise of the series Noah Hy actually
talked about how he feels the series in
some ways will mirror the life cycle of
xenomorph themselves how you get the egg
you then get the slow moving but
deliberate face hugger you then get the
impregnation and the parasite growing
within you then get the dramatic
explosion and reveal of the monster
before all hell breaks loose now that's
a really interesting analogy and it
suggests to me that Hy is thinking about
quite a slow burn show that builds up
towards a big finale that is clearly the
way to go and should be very very
interesting we're clearly going to have
another Series where the humans actually
look like more the villain than the
alien and there's going to be a lot of
backstabbing in fighting an office
politics going on but this series based
on is should really be an interesting
way of kickstarting and adding a lot
more depth to a series we already know
quite a lot about the xenomorph
franchise very much like the Predator
franchise has had a lot of sort of beta
Cannon over the years novels Comics etc
etc we know so much about both of these
I'm mentioning the Predator because I'm
really hoping that's where they end up
as this franchise develops over the next
next few years I want an AVP movie again
but I want it done
better this series though I'm hoping
will allow a lot of that beta Cannon to
become proper Cannon to get it up on the
screen for us to get a lot of that depth
and that rich history of these
Xenomorphs and get it on screen and I'm
really looking forward to New Life being
breathed into one of my favorite
franchises but what do you think get
into the comments is this movie and TV
serious something you are seriously
looking forward to or will Disney [__]
this up like they [__] everything else
up recently get to the comments and tell
me exactly what you think also if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to patreon.com citre most of our new
videos appear first and you get to see
them without the adverts also go to
s.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more detail for you to digest go
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time